the world will be watching st
louis the best in the us
the best in the world only one
will be king
the sinful cup
we've reached the final round here at
the sink field cup in st
louis and the excitement is palpable
it's
an energetic that's just absolutely
electric we see people coming from all
over the globe
chess journalists chess fans they're all
here to see some of their heroes
in action including world number one
magnus carlson
although we've actually got three
players today who are within striking
reach
of the single field cup it's uh
absolutely thrilling to be able
to agree to the game today with our
commentary
um look at the at the st louis club we
also have the world chess hall of fame
across the street this is
five years of history being made here
and this is really american chess
history in the making right now
absolutely the club is packed i couldn't
come down with yet
without getting all kinds of uh requests
for autographs and cameras and i'm not
even one of the players jen oh yeah me
too yesterday
some guy asked me to sign his abs whoa
there you go i'm jennifer shahadi this
is grandmaster yasser sarawan and along
with grandmaster maurice ashley
we're bringing you all the action today
here at the final round of the team
field cup
but let's look at what happened
yesterday
the big game on board one was hikaru
nakamura just a half a point behind
magnus carlson
needing to win nakamura was unable to
press
the world number one and the game ended
in a draw
i think it was a very well played game
both in attack and defense
none of us could avoid the repetition
without
weakening our position so it was a
pretty logical draw in the other
match-up
world number two lavon aronian hoped to
defeat tailander godakomski
but in the end he was under pressure and
the game ended in a draw
setting up a big final matchup between
the world's two best players
i don't want to go home and
think about missing my chances
well it's sports day in america tiger
woods making a run at the bmw
championship the manning brothers facing
off later in their big football rivalry
and of course yankees red sox one of the
most storied rivalries in all of sports
but hold up it's a new tradition the
sink field cup
final round action with world number one
magnus carlsen
going against his main rival on the
rating list lavon aronian
both of them vying for first place and
let's not forget hikaru nakamura
america's number one player with a win
today he could actually hold the trophy
by himself
or be in a tie for the playoffs we'll
see
what happens in final round coverage
here at the sinkfield cup
jen back to you let's take a look at the
standings um as they are
after five rounds we've got magnus
carlsen
in first place with three and a half
points so he has a chance to win this
tournament clear if he wins
half a point behind we've got our local
hero mikaro nakamura
three points best player in the u.s also
one of the best in the world
half a point behind him lavon oroneon
who has recovered from an
early blunder in round one and then
we've got gotta kamsky who has secured
last place and
our carlson aronian matchup today
will be critical right this is the
marquee this is the marquee game today
and uh carlson playing with the white
pieces and a draw will secure him at
least a playoff but we said an interview
that he was going to press
now we've also also got nakamura playing
against kamsky we've seen these two
battle before in the championship
nakamura now in a must-win situation
is going to try his best to make things
very interesting against gotta kamsky
absolutely now uh in the last time they
played
uh in a must win situation nakamura
responded to
goddess e4 with the sicilian it was open
najdorf and it was a really really
combative game that nakamura did win
and this is a great opening when you
need to play for
the win exactly and in fact that is what
happened
nakamura has repeated his u.s chess
championship victory opening
and is going for another lap exactly
so let's see how uh here in this
dramatic
final round of the sink fuel cup things
unfolded
um again gotakamsky the current u.s
champion playing
his nearest rival in america opened up
e4
and with this move we have the sicilian
knight f3
d6 d4 going for the open sicilian and as
you say this is the
leads to the most dynamic play uh of
any opening and the night in particular
and the night of in particular now in
that game that they played in the u.s
championship
gotta played 6a4 which is kind of
a little bit of an offshoot line that
being said he
usually he you can also play bishop e2
in conjunction with it but this time he
played
much more topically he played the move
six bishop e3
which is one of the most popular moves
in the opening that's right
called the english attack exactly the
idea is that often you're just going to
play
f3 queen d2 and queenside castle and
almost treat it
as though uh black played a dragon yes
and just playing as white for this
kingside
initiative and as you just mentioned
white skedaddles over here to the
queenside
with his king against bishop e3
gary kasparov blazed new paths
after bishop e3 with this move knight g4
and a lot of heavy theory
commences after this
sequence of moves right this is only one
of many lines black and dry
it's the most uh kind of it's not i
wouldn't say it's the most aggressive
it's the most concrete though
but um black also plays e6 and e5 here
that's right
nike for trying to instead immediately
take advantage of the fact that white
hasn't played f3 yet um and
has to put the question to the bishop
and the players have been playing
rapidly
if i was god i would consider just
because i'm knocking him in a muslin
situation i would consider after knight
d4 to move bishops he won just to really
annoy him
because that's like a little perpetual
yeah you
you mean uh the move bishop c1 knight
back to f6
and a repetition a very early repetition
to ignore
i mean it's it's really just pure
psychology because nakamura absolutely
can't take a draw so he would instantly
be forced to play either e5 or e6
correct
yes and um that might have been a little
a little clever psychological trick on
kamsky's part
what do you think or do you think it
would think it's too sleazy
no um i i just wouldn't have done it
just from the point of view
that uh as in being in goddess shoes
uh i believe in sportsmanship and
you know playing fearlessly and saying
okay i know the tournament situation i
know i'm doing badly
uh but i want to give you a fair shot
and let's play
uh a full game also although i don't
think it would be that
unsportsmanlike only because it would
just basically force nakamura to play a
line then he maybe had him prepared as
well because not because god knows that
naka couldn't play it
couldn't go for the repetition so he
would have to choose either e6 or e5
instead
you can't play e6 because the knight is
hanging uh
no i mean he would have to go back i'm
saying like after bishop c1
right knight f6 bishop e3 right he would
have to choose either e6 or e5 there
right that's what i'm saying so but
maybe gotta likes the lines with knight
d4 that's another
possibility and i think he does okay
let's go back through it for just a
second and how they got here
again it was the open eye door in a
little a little bit of disagreement
about there about whether that's
sportsmanlike or not let us know what
you think about these games and about
these issues here in the critical last
round don't forget
to use their hashtag sync cup s-i-n-q
exactly so bishop g5
this very forceful variation neither
player
neither grand master ducked these
mainline discussion bishop h4
and after the move g5 bishop g3
the idea from white's point of view is
he has weakened
the square f5 which makes a nice outpost
if white can secure that outpost he's
going to have an edge
on the other hand black with this move
bishop g7
he secures a very nice diagonal
for his bishop so contrasting
styles here h2h3 knight drop
back to f6 and let's see we have caught
up with the players
still a lot of theory from this position
going forward
the most common move is queen d2 and
let's take a look at our marquee matchup
as you pointed out um
we just couldn't take our eyes off this
exciting sicilian exactly
the carlson game is the one that could
decide the championship
um and rather the field cup outright
right um and this looks like
it's actually repeating nakamura aronian
from round one so we went into
a marshall type position let's take a
look an anti-marshal yes with a rui
lopez this is the signature move
bishop b5 on move three that
uh create gives the opening its name
we've seen a lot of ray lopez's in this
tournament so yeah
for those of you who are trying to study
this opening this this event
has been quite a treat absolutely and
sometimes
it's tough for amateur players because i
think e4 is more popular at the amateur
level
but a lot of the super gm tournaments
sees quite a lot of d4s and c4
so yes and world championship matches as
well that's right
so this tournament's been kind of nice
in that for e4 players i'm a d4 player
so
i don't mind it when they uh e4 on the
other hand
i think that these classical lines of
play that we're seeing
this is the most classical opening
position in chess
it's really good and beneficial
for amateur players and professional
players to have
these classical defense in your
repertoire
so finally i just want to go back here
for this moment
with this move rook e1 what this move
does
rookie 1 is it defends this pawn on e4
and it sets up this threat
of bishop takes c6 followed by this
capture of the pawn on e5
and that's why this move b5 is
automatically played
in most grand master games to dodge that
threat
now it's interesting that uh actually
carlson's last uh
victory i think against iranian was in
this line but instead of
the main lines with rookie one he played
d3 right
yeah method slow treatment and that was
in the london chess classic so here
instead uh perhaps uh thinking that
nakamura's game was quite pleasant and
he decided to follow suit
right yeah hikaru found a little
[ __ ] a dent if you will in the
defensive armor of lavon aronian
and played for this position and got a
good position out of it
but this move d4 takes e5
um okay still pretty standard
anti-martial there are other there's so
many choices of course but d takes e5
queen takes
and immediately magnus
traded queens going for an ending and
taking a lot of the life
out of the position from aronian's point
of view i think magnus
is basically with this queen trait
saying i'm trying to secure my
tournament position
and to reduce uh the risk of
losing this game so queen takes rook
takes knight d2
and have more play more moves been
played
yes they have i believe h7
h6 was played
by aronian stopping any
possibilities of knight on f3 to g5
and then magnus trotted out this move a
4 a5 oh very interesting strategic idea
by magnus here
what he's aspiring for
is the move bishop a4 to attack this
knight on c6
and as we've seen before try to capture
this pawn on e5
so uh early things are happening here
as aronian has a little problem that
he's going to solve
how he's going to defend that pawn on e5
is going to be a critical question
and the interesting thing is that this
game has followed the nakamura game
up into move move elect 10 where instead
of taking with the knight
which led to a richer middle game we now
have an interesting
end game where white has a nice ball but
that nakamura game
continued instead with knight takes e5
right and then i suppose the difference
is that
uh white decided to stay in the middle
game because maybe he played knight bd2
first
right and then knight d7 but for those
of you watching at home
one of the most obvious questions here
is why not if uh
if black took with the knight why
wouldn't white go for the end game
anyway
okay and i think that maybe one of the
reasons is that um
you know that knight on c6 you want to
keep more pieces on the board in order
to have like a real pool in this
and further more that night on c6 could
end up looking a little bit awkward what
do you think the reason is
i think that this ending with knight
takes
e4 isn't that bad in other words this
knight on c6
is not as effective as this knight on f3
and so the trade of knights is ending
doesn't give white that same advantages
that he was getting in the in the
earlier games
still a tiny pool but it feels like less
for white because that bishop coming to
b7 now will be directly hitting the pawn
on the e4
um yeah and even in this position knight
takes e4 is a little bit of a threat
so and also keep in mind when the two
knights were on the board
there was this idea of knight f3 to g5
uh and aronian had to spend an entire
tempo
to stop that threat all right and we've
got grandmaster maurice ashley
with some thoughts on a carl santorunian
as well
indeed jen well the last time aronian
faced a carlson into rue lopez he ended
up
losing and he must have bad memories of
that game it was as you mentioned in the
london chess classic
and carlson really showed some fine
technique
and power chess in the end of that game
if you take a look at this position
you see that carlson is already ahead by
a pawn in the position
his rook being under attack by a bishop
but he simply ignored it
with the move pawn to g6 sacrificing
an exchange here but if aronian had
actually captured this piece then after
d
takes he would have had these two pawns
to contend with
no way to stop them as a matter of fact
trying to attack this pawn
and stop it from going forward would
have been met by this move knight takes
f5
and suddenly black's position is just
frozen he could maybe bring his king
over
but that's not going to help pawn up and
look at this dominant position
carlson would have had king coming back
over this king marching up
and this could have been a nice finish
as well if the king goes here look at
this line knight takes
and if pawn takes pawn up and suddenly
the pawns alone
rule the chess board he decided to avoid
that line after this move g6
and he dropped back with bishop to g8
but now this pawn being on the board was
just too dominant
desperation time f4 king takes f4 trying
to get
the rook behind but the white pieces
just marched in easily
creating a pass pawn of his own but
after the move rook to f6
rookie two and then this rook down to f8
with check he resigned realizing that
after he
he had blocked knight takes pawn takes
and now the move c7
check picking off that rook and because
you have to take this pawn
and then the bishop's under attack he's
going to get behind the pawn so
a horrible memory for aronian that he
has to
erase from his mind so that he could win
today and have a chance
of winning the singfield cup back to you
jen and yes
oh boy trying to win this position with
black against the world's number one
it's it's a hard it's a hard task and
chess grand masters have
great memories uh we remembered
i'm going to say thousands of patterns
and the thing is in this particular
opening both players both lavon aronian
the world's number two as well as magnus
the world's number one
have a lot of experience this is a line
that they're
used to playing and they both know the
patterns exceedingly well
from black's point of view in this
position they have on the board is
this pawn on e5 is a potential weakness
and usually what black has to do you
mentioned jen
there are there are ideas or even issues
with utilizing this rook on d8 so that
you could play a knight takes e4
with a back rank check at a particular
moment black has to play
very active with his pieces and the move
bishop e7
c5 is the type of move that really
fits into the position for black as
he wants to remind white of ideas like
knight g4
the bishop on c5 takes up a very active
post
putting pressure on the f2 pawn and i
think
he's actually played it yes he has so he
has played the move bishop c5
and now magnus has to carefully consider
his choices should he
play the same uh waiting move
with the move h2h3 as did uh aronian a
moment ago
aronian played h6 to prevent knight g5
maybe magnus plays h3 to prevent knight
g4
so the player still jockeying out of the
opening in
this the crucial game
obviously if magnus can win the other
game
between gata and hikaru doesn't
have an impact on first place if aronian
wins then opens up the door
for hikaru to go clear first wow
a big throw for the st louis local fans
now
it is true that levon is playing in some
ways for
a possible jump in prize money so let's
take a look at the prizes here
at the sink field cop now the first
prize will not be split
the winner of the single cup will get 70
grand got it but the other prizes will
be split if there's a tie
so second place is 50k and third place
is 30 000
so lavon also has something to play for
in the sense that if he draws this game
and nakamura loses
then he can also gain ten thousand
dollars
with the split of second and third so
there's something else to play for there
but i
i do feel it's i unders i totally
understand the long yesterday said he's
not gonna play any differently based on
the tournament
situation but you do wonder because
there's just like such a big difference
between
drawing the difference between losing
and drawing both financially and
prestige prestige-wise isn't that
high but the difference between winning
and drawing is massive
that's right so i wonder if he if
there's anything he could have done with
his openings i know he always plays e5
but it does make you wonder isn't it
cool that nakamura has a sicilian
up his sleeve for situations like that
even though he's not as high ranked as
lavon it almost seems that
his repertoire in this case is more
suited to the tournament situation
absolutely uh hikaru has a broader uh
opening repertoire
and in a sense lavon is a specialist
if you will in the classical king pond's
defenses
so you you go with what brought you to
the party
and lavon you know as you say may
uh have liked to have the opportunity to
play something a little bit more daring
and dangerous
but he was true to himself in this
particular game
sure i mean he is number two in the
world he doesn't want to lose that
ranking either so that's another
consideration
and we've got grand master mauricio for
some thoughts on this discussion
well following right with what you said
jen about hikaru nakamura having a
sicilian
the time that he played this exact
variation
against godakomski that is the night off
he has
had a great time of it he won the game
and
must be having good memories and got it
with bad memories let's take a look this
came from the u.s championship
last year and this was the critical
position
it was all to play for and nakamura with
this super sharp position having already
won an exchange
decided right at this moment was the
time to give it back with the
spectacular sacrifice rook takes on d5
pawn takes on d5 and then bishop
captures
on a5 of course the knight cannot
capture because it is pinned to the rook
after rook to e7 he played the very nice
move bishop back to b6
protecting his rook and preparing to
march the pony down the board
the pawn went to d6 but now the move
pawn to a5 was played
and suddenly you couldn't advance this
because there was a pin happening
on the b7 square so after king to g5
by kamsky past pause must be pushed
as we all learn in grade school the pawn
just marched down the board
to a3 and then knight to d8 a bit of
desperation hoping for some tactical
tricks
nakamura would have none of it just
simply played a2 and after a little
trickery 96 check
king to h6 and then knight g5 with some
kind of idea
nakamura said i don't believe you go
right ahead
one last spike check and then king to g7
and kamsky
resigned so as you said jen nakamura has
a sharp opening in his repertoire
he's hoping for this kind of play where
his tactical ability
will come to the surface and maybe even
win the game
and give him a real shot of being in the
playoffs or maybe even mathematically
winning outright
the singfield cup back to you jenny yes
and that is why we love nakamura you can
always count on him
bring the fire when he needs to and keep
us on the edge of our seats uh
we know it's going to be a dramatic last
round uh the buzz here is really
palpable
and i tell you uh with hikaru his
mercurial temper
we just got to sit and admire and see
what he's going to pull
if he can pull a rabbit out of his head
winning with black on this
elite levels is extremely difficult so
a big challenge for him but quite
capable of delivering
as maurice just showed us yeah i agree
and i think that it's nice you know you
see
nakamura develop as a player he does
have that more solid side to him now too
yeah they got the maturing uh process
going on you're not seeing so many queen
h5s and things like that
but uh even yesterday you felt a lot of
people felt maybe he played almost too
solidly against magnus
yeah his opening choice that on one hand
seemed aggressive but on another
led to too symmetrical of a position
yeah it was
it was a date played by him
uncharacteristically so
um i think both players were hoping the
other was going to take
a great deal of risk and magnus said
fine i'll play solidly
and try to make a draw here we see
typically hikaru at the board
and you know he seems to be looking at
the ceiling but what he's really going
through
is these mental files of all of the
variations
that he's prepared for this tournament
and tournaments before of course
and he's trying to choose a variation
that he feels will give him the most
dynamic possibilities of pulling out a
victory
not so easy to get the exact variation
you want
and grandmasters are constantly
weighing this different variations
as to what is going to give them the
best chance winning
that's right well i remember that u.s
championship
with uh kamsky and nakamura was really
thrilling because they both played such
great chess
it's true and it all came down in fact
it was even kanski who was impressing a
little bit more throughout the
tournament but
then it came down to this game where
nakamura just uh brought it
to pain true and i remember being here
in the st
louis chess club when that uh that
championship was up for grabs
and in this very room where
it was just full of spectators and
everybody uh including
our rex uh sync field uh
was that oh really okay we're on the
edge of the seats i mean that was
a wonderful day for chess marvelous it
was a great day for tess and it's nice
to see that it's really the whole thing
is expanded right now we don't have a
live audience which we missed
but yes at the other at the same time
we've got massive live audiences
over at lester's and upstairs to watch
the games live but we've got
um we've got grand masters ian rogers
we've got
grand masters raroushi nakobian ronin
hearts v
and ben feingold and they're doing
commentary at the world chess hall of
fame
and lester's right because even one live
commentary space is not enough
to host all the fans here for the sink
field cup in fact
there's three commentary because they're
following us upstairs too
so we've yeah so we've lost uh we've
come a long way
from having a packed basement now we
have
back central west end that's it that's
it that's precisely right
so let me just uh bring our boards up to
date as the players
carefully consider their their opening
variations and
after this move bishop c5 interesting
interestingly enough a5 bishop c5
magnus played this move bishop bishop
b3 to c4 now i don't think he could have
predicted bishop c5 apparently this move
is new because these six have been
played previously
okay so bishop c4 a strange move what do
you think that's about
well uh two things uh
twofold in the first place remember jen
again you had mentioned that there was
always this potential for back rank
mating possibility
with this move bishop c4 what white has
done
is said okay i'm going to stop you from
ever having those
options because i'll have be able to
play bishop back
to f1 to defend my king but more
saliently
what i think white is playing for is to
bring his knight
to this b3 square let's go back just a
moment get rid of some
arrows the move bishop c4 was played and
again the idea is this bishop on c5
is along with this rook on d8 these are
two
white blacks pardon me two most active
pieces
and let me just make a choice for black
for a moment
just to show what i think magnus is up
to
he's opened up the b3 square for his
knight
in order to attack this bishop so that
after the bishop is driven back
magnus can play the move bishop e3 and
in case of a trades of bishops
he's opened up this very nice outpost
the c5 square for his knight
if he can put his knight on the c5
square
white has makings
of a very a nice strategic game
that's right i mean we've mentioned this
before that in the royal lopez sometimes
the end games are pleasant for white
because of the holes that are created
when you play these moves a6 and b5
right and that's why we also see
that in the black side of the roy lopez
a lot of the victories by black
have to do more with activity right like
on magnus's side
where he actually had a worse pawn
structure
but you know got this mating attack
against kanski which forced kamsky to
give up a pawn
right exactly and so
early jockeying in this
anti-marshal between magnus
and aronian again i think that lavonne
has a great deal of experience in
this particular branch of
the rui lopez
and so none of these moves will really
come
as a big surprise for uh
aronian i think if i were in black shoes
here even though i've been
louding the activity of this rook on d8
there's something to be said for rook e8
followed by bishop e6
this bishop on c4 is a strong bishop
and that bishop on c8 is at the moment
undeveloped
passive so that maneuver of trading the
bishops has a very logical flow
to my eyes let me just go back to the
kamsky game for a moment
yeah sure that one is fiery yeah
those players have been playing very
quickly and it's like
everybody knows what they're doing here
so let's find out what happened
again we mentioned that this was this
came from an
english treatment of the night or knight
g4
uh a trail blazed by gary kasparov
in this line with black all of these are
very standard moves
h3 attacking the knight and driving the
knight backwards
knight f6 bishop c4 and this is an
ultra aggressive treatment by white what
white
is trying to do is cement him
his queen side decision by putting the
bishop back
on the b3 square for defensive
reasons but also for offensive reasons
the bishop is
really powerful on the a2
g8 diagonal against bishop c4
hikaru played queen
d8 to v6 uh
attack with a direct attack against the
b2 pawn
as well as an ambush idea
of ambushing this knight on d4 thanks to
this bishop on g7
lurking uh from the g7 square we're
calling one of bobby fischer's
favorite lines the poison pond just
going after b2
it's very similar to the poison pond
neither
yes of course bishop b3 just guards the
bomb
well yes it it definitely defends the b2
pawn
now you've got to ask yourself about you
always have to ask yourself about a move
like knight takes e4
precisely uh knight c6 was icaru's
choice and it seems to me he played that
move very quickly whereas i'm not
completely familiar with the theory of
this line
i would have certainly looked at this
move knight takes e4
the idea once more is that this bishop
on g7
and this queen on b6 simultaneously
attack this knight on d4 so if
if this move knight takes e4 is possible
or not
first sighting i don't see why
this move could not have been played
it's good to try to figure it out
ourselves right
right i mean what uh yeah so knight d5
allows queen to a5 jack right i mean we
do have bishop
bishop we have things like queen f3
we're gonna just take this guy that's
true too that's possible as well
i mean i was thinking knight c7 check
but the knights can have some trouble
getting out
right and i've got a nice central pawn
there's also some potential tactics on
f7 but i don't know if those are going
to work out for us
at all because it's because d4 is
hanging in the end right
right so if we for instance if we were
to play um
so for example let's say knight takes e4
queen takes d4
queen f3
i mean at the moment we've sacrificed a
pawn
and it's not completely clear to me we
could sacrifice another pawn play for
rapid development as this enough
not so sure let's take it back a step
because i'm not convinced that that
would be adequate
so again knight takes e4 what was wrong
with this you mentioned queen f3
directly as a possibility
well i guess it could work because the
the the kind of um
the the reason i i rejected it so
quickly was because i saw like you you
can also just play knight f6 but then
knight d5 might be interesting as well
i don't know but even this line i don't
see anything
well yeah i mean okay we could
again continue this line rook d8
and this is still not convincing to my
my eyes i mean
okay black's king has lost the ability
to castle but at the moment
it seems safe enough remarkable i'm not
sure what the theory is
and i certainly would have given knight
takes e4
uh consideration but again well he
probably did it at home and for some
reason
because they're playing so quickly
clearly they've looked at these
variations
precisely i think maybe nakamura
considered knight takes e4 at home and
then rejected it for some reason
but it does look tempting and that's
another lesson about the sicilian you've
got to look at these things
um normally the bishops on e3 and
guarding and
yeah i was looking at that possibility
of just playing knight to f6
right and now that i'm thinking about it
i believe there was a game
that alexander grishok um
played with this line
um i don't remember that well because
it's not in my repertoire apparently
it's not
played actually no knight takes e4 no
okay
confusing at least by at least by a
strong player that's what i i
i'm getting word that it hasn't really
been played but after knight takes e4
um well fire up your engines and
send us a twitter yeah um knight takes
e4 queen d4
queen e2 um is one possibility here just
kind of threatening on
d6 right i think you looked at this
variation
and you saw that after castles i mean
white certainly has some compensation
but far from clear absolutely i mean
it is a as we know the center ponds are
uh the most vital ponds that we have in
chess
and crucial for our control over the
center
here black has two center pawns to none
for white
so from a strategic point of view and a
material point of view black is doing
great
the only question is if he can weather
the storm on
against his king and there's definitely
some aggressive possibilities here after
for instance c3 protecting the pawn
and all right and then you know trying
to get in uh queenside castles
yeah i do i do find uh white's activity
to be appealing but um
is it enough is it enough it's a
question so though somebody's gonna try
this soon after watching this broadcast
i'm sure grab that pawn snap it off well
like i say fire up those chess engines
send us a twitter
let us know what we're missing uh or
whether this
uh was simply too dangerous a line
and uh well maybe we'll just simply ask
maurice how's that
there we go i guess there's a reason why
i have a job here right so
i went and did the research myself and
it turns out that
komski's line of bishop c4 is not a
popular move not really essayed
by a lot of players in this position
instead of playing the move bishop to c4
in yeah in this position here after
knight f6 actually
bishop c4 is an okay line after queen b6
the move the key move bishop to b3 is
actually the one that is not often
played you can simply castle here
in this position this has been played
before by uh gary kasparov
we might have heard of that guy in this
line in
because the pawn is not really something
you can take after queen to b6
the possibilities of trapping the queen
in the position so a lot of tactics
there
bishop to b3 has been played and no one
at least in my database has tried to
take the pawn on e4
i think because it's fairly dangerous
seeing this line after queen to
f3 although it looks as though knight f6
and you're just sort of
up a pawn even the engines are saying
this position is good for
white after bishop to a4 check and this
move
knight to d7 and simply castling guys
how you like that just going down a pawn
but saying so what i have all the
development your pieces are locked in
and it's even giving king f8 as the best
move you can imagine that
it doesn't like castles here because of
knight to f5
and suddenly wise pieces are making a
great impression on the position
so very unclear if you want to play this
with black be ready to have to suffer a
little bit
being up that pawn so far no one has
wanted to be
in that kind of position and nakamura
decided
nah i'm not going there in this the last
round of the sink field cup
back to you jen and yaz thank you
maurice and we see uh
nakamura rocking his chess club and
scholastic center st louis t-shirt his
also his
casper chess foundation badge and a
patch rather
and meanwhile making a lot of faces this
we love
nakamura at the chess table thankfully
not the poker table
right well here again we're seeing the
richness
of the game of chess and how grand
masters
bring their little nuances and
subtleties and ideas
to uh even the most theoretical
opening variations so bishop c4
astraying off the beaten path by
godakamsky
queen b6 bishop b3 that's the novel
i well not the novel idea the standard
idea had been castles
marie cited a game that gary kasparov
played with the black pieces
and not this move knight takes e4
because
again what maurice was saying was that
queen f3
knight f6 bishop a4
check to the black king knight d7
the computers felt that white's
compensation for just one pawn
is very good and optically just looking
at the position once white
plays this move rook on h1 to e1 it
really does
have that impression of all of white's
forces being
in the game everything's developed
everything is out
and black still has a lot of development
problems to solve
that's true in the poison pawn as well
and that didn't stop bobby that didn't
stop bobby fischer from making it his
favorite weapon that's true
but so a dangerous line of play
i would say for both players but in this
now that i'm looking at the position
just
as we say with beginner's eyes or you
know for the first time
it does look like this is too dangerous
a line
for hikaru so he didn't
go for the pawn let's see what happened
instead instead he played knight to c6
and revealed
another purpose of his queen on b6 right
so afternoon c6 knight takes c6
usually in these types of sicilians we
often like to take with the b-pawn
so that we can have the rook on the open
file and also have plenty of control
over d5
but this one's a little bit different
because i feel that
white might be able to get in a
well-timed e5 here maybe just
simply immediately immediately
and if you could as white force the
trade of these two pawns
once white plays queen e2 and castles
either side really
he's going to looking like he has right
a nice structure and there are more
targets and weaknesses in
in black's camp than whites right
normally when bkxc6 happens it's
pleasant for black because it improves
the structure but here we've actually
heard our structure and the rook b8 idea
doesn't it's not even possible that's
right so uh that
that might be one of the reasons that uh
nakamura decided to take with the queen
and of course now he can also play b5
and the e4 pawn
is under threat now the negative side is
that the d5 square
looks like a juicy possibility for white
someday as is often true
um when you're on the white side of the
sicilian and black plays a line which
doesn't include pawn to e6 i i once
recall a conversation i had with the
legend of anderson grand master from
sweden and really one of the world's
great positional players and i asked him
i said ulf
what do you think about the dragon i was
really
intrigued by the dragon and tony miles
at the time was a big dragon
uh fan i love it i know and you know
what it all said to me
you can't play it the dragon is
unplayable i said
what the sicilian dragon one of those
dynamic variations in chess is
unplayable
why he said the d5 square is too weak oh
dear
but he was he how how was he having an
opinion on a position without with
queens on the board
were you surprised all of oath
studied a lot of variations in his life
he was a
real chess lover and he uh
loved analyzing uh positions as well but
in this
exact position you really get an
impression of what olf's talking about
here because if you're looking at that
d5 square
you're going to move your queen you're
going to castle you're going to play
knight d5
it's quite obvious that white's play is
simple
and strong let's see how things
develop from here i'm going to close it
and i'm going to come back
so that we can see properly see the
times yeah and let's also get an update
actually after queen takes e6 white did
castle kingside
so i think taking your cue from ulf
there and saying like i'm going to get
the d5 square and not take a lot of risk
by trying to castle queen side so um
definitely
an interesting point just the funny
thing about wolf is i hear this legend
that he'd like to play blitz chess
without queens
yeah i don't mind that hilarious i know
it's kind of a contradiction most people
who play blitz want to go
tac-tac-tac-tac right and then to do it
without queens it's just like
interesting like who does that well he's
just a lover of the end game
here in this case white's e4 pawn is not
hanging
this time for a different reason you
can't capture the pawn on e4
remember ol's admonishment the d5 square
is too weak in this case
there's a double attack against the
queen as well as the knight
black doesn't mean we were castled
knight takes e3 would be a great
rejoinder but here unfortunately
in between move met by counter in
between with a check
that's right hey the check you don't
have time don't be reaching for your
knight and capturing my
queen uh reach for this bishop because
it's checking
your king so that was a party yeah
that's why knight takes e4 in
that position was unplayable very
quickly by the way
quite surprisingly
hikaru spanked down g5 g4
right away so this position
hikaru was saying i know this one i've
studied
i'm playing g5 g4 and that is
going for the attack even though we're
always taught that
develop your pieces first and then look
for the attack here
with his king in the center of the board
with his queen side pieces undeveloped
there's hikaru and we know he's
temperamental
and mercurial but also dynamic
playing for the attack without having
developed his pieces this is a no-no a
cardinal sin in chess
but he's done it in the most important
final round with everything up for grabs
yeah and chess is very concrete we've
seen nakamura make anti-positional moves
before in this tournament
and get the better of it so this is this
uh kind of along that same trend uh i
was i'm thinking about his b5 against
magnus carlson
all right um this looks g5 and d5
right yeah so here we going again here
we go again
and i think the idea is that he wants to
be able to develop that bishop on c8 in
one move
and then uh where he does it with a
tempo you mean
yeah exactly i don't know where he's
trying to castle here
we're both confused on that score i
would say that
i'm not 100 sure i want to play the move
f2
f3 potentially weakening my king shield
something more along the lines of queen
d3
playing for knight d5 that looks like it
could
lead to a sizable advantage for white
only because i don't like this
structure for black and in particular
this pawn on h6 it
looks like a weakness to me that really
sits stands out like a sore thumb
things don't look quite right here for
black because it just seems hard
your coordination is starting to come
together but without the kings and the
king and the rooks connecting it's
it's not quite there and exactly because
of the development
yeah i mean d5 even if we had our king
um you know shuffled away
right um the d5 score would still be an
issue but it's kind of like the d5
square
and the king position it just seems that
white should be always have something up
his sleeve
right and again these kinds of king-side
attacks when the center isn't fixed
is particular dane particularly
dangerous for the second player
because hicaro is always going to have
to worry
that a well-timed e4 e5 might just spin
the
position out of control uh and he would
be subject to
a massive counter attack that's right i
mean i it from a visual point of view it
looks really
unpleasant for black but you know it's a
pretty concrete game and
nakamura probably has analyzed these
lines and maybe think that it's
better than it looks well yeah and
well here's the other one when we kind
of just take the position back
one move when hikaru played the move g5
g4
essentially this really puts the onus on
on white
because this pawn on h3 is under attack
so it's a hundred percent certain
that uh gada was going to capture the
spawn on g4
and then much to my surprise it was a
hikaru actually was thinking several
minutes
for what seems to us to be very obvious
move
he needed to develop and recapture the
pawn
so bishop takes g4 was the most natural
move but it took him some time
to actually make that decision and
rather surprising since everything is so
forced
and so concrete well you've talked about
this before how you don't understand how
players think when force moves do you
think it's a waste of time
indeed and a mistake but i mean it seems
like so many players do it it's almost
like they're trying to
acquaint themselves psychologically like
center themselves because
usually at this level time pressure it's
an
issue but with the 30 second increment
it's not like it used to be
it's not like it's not like oh you know
a few minutes here and there is gonna
cause a disaster especially for such a
sharp player
like nakamura for him perhaps just
reaching his psychological center is
more important
and we saw that psychology is very
important to him wearing those
sunglasses against magnus
so that you didn't have to face a stare
down
well again i mean in chess there's a lot
of
uh things that the players have to be
aware of obviously good
moves speak the loudest that sometimes
time management
can be key we've seen a couple of time
trouble
uh mistakes and you know
sometimes when you sit there and you are
in time trouble you think to yourself
why did i spend three minutes five
minutes eight minutes
in the opening leaking my clock away
over a forced decision hopefully it
won't come back to
bite hikaru and we've got grandmaster
maurice ashley for
his thoughts on the position now
well jen i did a bit more digging into
this line
and black has to be a little bit careful
here obviously
his pawn structure his inability to
castle the queen coming out very early
is all the sort of thing that we learned
back in grade school
don't do that to yourself but of course
on the grand master level we break all
the rules
and play the exceptional ideas that's
how you win games
i did look at a game between
kasparov on the white side i might add
versus
judit polgar a classic game that they
played
and in this position instead of bishop
to b3 gary actually
castled here again offering the
delectable looking pawn on e4 except
judith decided
nah that's not that one doesn't look
tasty to me because after knight takes
knight takes and the natural queen takes
d4 looking like you're attacking
a couple of pieces maybe trading off
queens up a pawn this is
met by the devastating knight takes d6
check right in the middle of the board
ripping the king's
protection to shreds and now this move
queen to e2 check
and you can't block with this bishop
obviously because of the trade on e6
and if you block with the other bishop
then the move rook to d1
chasing the queen and after queen c5 a
vicious sacrifice
rook takes on d6 kicking the legs from
under this bishop
and after queen takes d6 bam a bishop
takes e5 hitting the queen
and the rook so there's some danger in
trying to be greedy grabbing that pawn
so we can understand
why nakamura even against bishop b3 said
now
i'm not interested back to you jen and
jazz
those are nice examples of the types of
tactics
uh that black is subjected to
when your king is being left in the
center and that was
typical gary kasparov fireworks
sparkling fireworks there in that game
we did see this move
i was a little reluctant
it's very nice in the opening to gain
time
by attacking your opponent's pieces and
this move
f2f f3
the bishop having attacked the queen
it's really nice to be able to return
the favor with move f2
f3 i actually like these pawns
on f2 and g2 because they
offer white's king great protection you
don't want to make that weakness
i don't and i'm very unhappy that my
queen is
undeveloped so in this case rather than
the move queen
d1 to d3 which was my first instinctive
move
ghada has just developed this queen with
queen d2 and now he's preparing
the very obvious rook on a1
to e1 followed by knight d5 and he's
hoping that he's going to get a firm
safe advantage with
this line of play yeah it definitely
does look like a promising opening for
white
but you know a keen choice by nakamuri
in that he wanted to try
to play something dynamic today but
maybe his specific choice didn't quite
work
um we've got some great uh comments
coming in
to our hashtag sync cop one said that uh
sam thompson actually said that lev said
he would equalize first and then push to
win
therefore lev is playing for a win right
now and you're right sam lavonne did say
that he was going to play an opening
like this and play his normal chess
play to equalize then see if he could
push something out of it unfortunately
his opponent magnus carlsen makes the
second part of that plan
a little bit harder than most very
difficult and
we've also got a comment um
we've got some comments in spanish so
it's nice to see that we have people
watching all over the world we've got a
comment from um tarties fenson who's
been tweeting at us
all tournament he's a journalist from
norway and he makes a great point that
if magnus carlsen wins the sinkfield cup
it will be his 11th tournament win
out of his last 17 classical tournaments
wow and he uses the hashtag domination
for sure no reason indeed wow
that's like winning 11 out of 17 majors
or something that's just incredible
that's a fantastic record
but that's a big if because we still got
plenty of play here at the sink field
cop
and we do have our um namesake here
rex sinkfield who founded the chess
clubs classic center in st louis here
with genie zinfield his wife and he's
going to talk a little bit about the
tournament
and all the great things that are
happening in lewis
boy the st louis chess club will just
let anybody in huh i know right
but we are very honored to have
rexingfield with grandmaster maurice
ackley
thanks jen with rexingfield the sponsor
of the sinkhole cup the founder
of the saint louis chess club and
scholastic center
rex i'm just wondering how did you get
that shirt you know they just
they really just give it to anybody
don't they apparently they do they
dropped their standards i got in line i
got one
well thanks so much for being here
pleasure rex it's been such a tremendous
tournament
it's been wonderful for us to talk about
it how have you felt about
how things have transpired over this
last minute oh it succeeded my
wildest expectations you know what
people
outside the united states don't know is
that st louis has a terrific reputation
as a sports town
now right next to us what they also
don't know is lester's a very famous
sports bar in the city of st louis and
yesterday it was filled to capacity the
manager said they've never had a crowd
that big and the same thing will happen
today
and what drew those crowds not football
or baseball but
chess match this match was shown on
every screen in leicester sports bar and
it filled the place
that's absolutely incredible i think you
guys have a football team or
baseball team i'm not really sure about
that
but you have a vision you had a vision
for chess and now it seems to just be
coming true in an incredible way how are
you going to do better than this
uh you know it's difficult first of all
the way things have evolved we have to
give credit to
incredible staff that we have and to
commentators like you and yasser and
jennifer and the other folks but the
staff is amazing it seems like
everything we've tried has been
amazingly successful
always exceeding our expectations this
match is no exception
you know next year we want to do this
again and perhaps make it a little
larger
and we've been fortunate to host the u.s
uh championship and the women's
championship and the junior championship
five years in a row we'll do that again
next year
so it's amazing and our scholastic
effort i repeat what i said the other
day scholastic is in our title
that's really our mission children we're
already in a hundred schools if you told
me that five years ago i would have had
you locked up in a mooney bin
now tell me why chess why is this
scholastic effort so important to you
well because we know that chess is
really good for children and education
is one of the things i care about deeply
and we really wanted to locate this club
in or near the inner city of st louis so
we could get to the most underprivileged
schools and the most underprivileged
kids
and we were fortunate in finding this
space in
one of the most incredible neighborhoods
in the united states the central west
end here in st
louis and so it's one of the callings i
have in in the public policy arena and
chess overlaps that in case of education
now i would be remiss if i didn't ask
your grandmaster opinion of these games
so what do you think about this position
right now
i say that tongue-in-cheek obviously i
know you do i i know you do i'm actually
kind of interested in the way nakamura's
game evolved because as jennifer knows i
play the dragon a lot and he sort of
evolved into what's it called a dragon
dorf
wow man quoting some some
inside lingo i know that's okay you can
quote me
but so i'm i'm intrigued by that
position and obviously i'm very
interested and see how
how it goes well you're obviously a
great fan for chess and a great sponsor
for chess we appreciate
everything you do and the obvious
astuteness you have in choosing us as
broadcasters
and no matter how i try say it again try
otherwise
i always seem to end up liking you
anyway thanks for having us thank you
i've always questioned your judgment
and i didn't choose you joy chose you to
say
rexingfield a heck of a guy sponsor of
all things good in st louis we are
really blessed to have him on our show
thank you so much frank thank you
back to you jenny yes good interview
indeed and our twitter is blowing up
with appreciation uh for the sinfields
here in st
louis and there's one thing they caught
on that rex said that they love the most
and unsurprisingly that is the intention
to host this again next year
wonderful and even to expand the field
right
mention an expansion but i'd just like
to correct rex for a moment
he's absolutely right about the staff
but it's not a hundred schools
he's going to be shocked to realize it's
actually 500 schools
so he's behind the times a bit he
doesn't realize
how deep the reach of the st louis chess
club has
has gone into the school systems here in
the st
louis oh it's incredible just really
moving to see all that coincide there's
there's great scholastic chess programs
around the country
but the combination of the fantastic
scholastic chess program
and the elite chess they bring here
right is unprecedented right
that is nice and you know it's that
combination of
education and the caring for kids and
the appreciation of this art form
that i think will make it even longer
lasting than uh
any nhs movement that we've had in
america right and then you've got it
what you just referred to there in the
art really if you haven't visited it's
so beautiful the world chess hall of
fame
right across the street on some of the
montage of the videos that you saw you
saw some of those
incredibly beautiful ebony and ivory
sets uh just wow they're they're
it's definitely worth a visit and the
world chess hall of fame just turned two
years old
so happy birthday
and let's take some a look at some
photos of the world chess hall of fame
so
well that does give you goosebumps that
video we got five years for the st louis
chess club two for the world hall of
fame um
it was great to see some of our top
female players in america our reigning
women's champions
uh you know holding high her oversized
check right
we also saw anna zatonski and rusadango
luciani in there and
speaking of women's chess the world
championship match
over in china correct has been uh
underway three games have been played
three games and two and a half out of
three
for the chinese lady hui fan has taken a
uh commanding lead over the reigning uh
world champion from the ukraine ussenia
that's right so
wow big big things going on in china
even
as we come to a dramatic finish
ourselves and i was talking to my
brother who founded the us chess school
and he's mentioned that women's chess
seems to be going in a really good
direction in america
because you've got these great women's
championships but there's also a number
of very young players right now
who are 11 12 already 2 000 players
so i have a feeling we're going gonna
see and a lot of that's this extra
glamour and attention to chess i think
it really helps
um especially for women um to take up
the game so
i think we're gonna see some really good
things in american women's chess in the
next 10 years
well as we know in the country of
georgia georgia for
decades have has been leading women's
chess
the strongest players in the world
almost always came from
georgia and georgia had culturally has
really been supportive of women
playing chess but now that's really
blossoming and we're seeing especially
in china
that the chinese chess federation is
making a big big push
for women's chess in china and china has
been producing
female world champions that have
competed very successfully and might add
against the georgian ladies
that's right yeah and uh clarissa yip i
think she was covered in time magazine
recently just 11 years old already 2
000. wow so yeah some some really nice
things to all the girls and
women watching this uh keep it up we'd
like to see a female participant one way
one day uh
700 plus playing in a tournament like
this absolutely it could happen
and let me just go to some uh play for a
moment
major things have happened in the
marquee match
up between the world number one and
world's number two
black's position aronian has taken some
very consequent strategic
uh decisions in this game after the move
bishop c4 was played
magnus did not play the move h2h3
he's basically saying to levon ironian
i'm not
worried about this threat of knight f6
to g4
lavona roya said well shame on you you
should have been worried about the
threat
i'm going to play knight g4 with a
double attack against the pawn on
f2 thanks to my bishop and knight the
rook had to
pop up to e2 defending the f2 pawn
and now this huge huge strategic move by
aronian
i mentioned earlier that it was in
black's interest to trade those bishops
i didn't want to do it at the risk
of a double pawn on e6
but aronian took that risk as we know
strategically this is
long-term extremely damaging
to aronian but short term
aronian is saying look i got this
activity
i got the square i'm controlling a lot
of squares
we see the the next pair of moves
h3 driving back the night and i think
i'm caught up i apologize i'm not
one more move by magnus carlson rook e2
to e1 and he's anticipating a further
rerouting of the knight h5 to f4
right to dodge that and perhaps also to
get out of the way
of a possible knight d4 in the near
future
right so potentially straighten uh black
spawns out or allow for further activity
right so some very bold play by lavon
aronian
he's definitely has very active pieces
again
i'll mention at the risk of overstating
it
this rook on d8 is very well placed but
is this pawn structure uh damage pawn
structure worth the activity
not so sure i'm going to ask maurice for
his insight
maurice well yes sir
this is something really interesting
happening
in this round today we know it happens
to all of us
in final round play you either need a
win
or a draw to secure first place to
secure
the money what do you do well there's a
quote
that when you need a draw in in the last
round
you should play for a win don't start
playing tepid chess
because that's a sure route to getting a
bad position because you're not really
trying anymore
in this game it looks as though magnus
carlsen is playing safety first
and subsequently allowing levon aronian
to take
over the position and in fact at this
moment the computers
like black's position despite that weird
pawn structure
you see there i'd like to show you
something that has happened in this game
very quickly
in this moment we saw magnus capture on
e5 one of the great strengths of carlson
i've noticed
is whenever he's playing four win he
doesn't trade anything he lets you trade
but in this case he started the hoover
fest by taking here
and then after queen takes d8 rook takes
and then we saw knight
bd2 h6 play this small move a5 bishop to
c5
and then bishop to c4 and it was in this
moment
as you mentioned he has knight to g4
attacking the f2 pawn
rook up to e2 and then bishop to e6 and
now
he was attracted to the idea of trading
himself especially since the back rank
was a little bit weak but more trades on
his part
and we should note this f-file is also
open
for black the move h3 now knight back to
f6 and now the move rookie one it looks
as if he's shuffling back and forth
again we've seen him do this with his
rooks
before back and forth shuffling not
clear what he's doing but right now
the programs are saying it's black
for choice in this position black has
all the dynamism
he could play a move like knight to d4
now
entering the position attacking this
pawn and after
knight takes and rook takes and you can
see the clear difference in activity
between black's pieces and white pieces
not
clear that this is the best line to go
forever white me
may be able to go for and move like
knight b3 but in this position there's
even an active move believe it or not
like g5 another crazy line
he might consider i doubt levon is going
to go this sharp but the computers are
just
suggesting this line as well now i'd
like to flip over to the other game
because chess has all these principles
but it's often conflict the other one is
when you need a win in the last round it
often makes sense not to go for it not
to go crazy
and sacrifice everything and act like
you're a madman is to play solid chess
we've seen kasparov do this
before in the world championship match
against karpov when he needed to win in
the last game
and played a ready system in one of
their world championships played real
quiet let the tension build
and build contrarily in this game we see
nakamura
simply going for it with this wild
position
breaking his structure up on the king
side as you can see here
so interesting strategies on the part of
these top
players not your standard strategies in
this situation
but we'll see how it works out for them
as the games proceed here at
the final round in the sink field cup
back to you jen and yaz
great point maurice i mean i i was
totally thinking about the same thing
about that corollary we hear so often
that if you're playing for a draw you
should play for a win
right but how often do we hear that if
you're playing for a win
you should first play to equalize well
levon said it on the show yesterday
right but definitely a great point and
when maurice was talking about the rules
and principles of strategies
i can't help but remember with a big big
smile
my dear friend john grandmaster john
vanderville
from holland he had gone to work and
trained with the legendary victor
korchnoy
and during their analysis session victor
court john
suggested a move that violated our
beloved
opening principles and victor looked at
him and said
john before you violate the rules of
chess you should first
know them it was one of the best put
downs
i still laugh whenever i hear about the
principles of chess i think about that
story
but a very nice point that you were
making there maurice
about even though lavonne has this awful
ugly
pawn structure he has some great
activity
and although you said maurice that the
move g7
g5 is not the type of move that lavone
might play you know what i really like
that move
i like that move a great deal because
black has already burned his bridges so
to speak in terms of the strategical
side of things
and he's really got to go for it and i
like this idea of just playing for the
attack with g5
g4 you're most likely that he won't play
it
but i do like this move a lot and i'm a
positional player but this is uh
the most dynamic aggressive approach
that black can take
in this position so not disappointing us
here not
at all not at all even though queens are
off the board we have a pretty exciting
and uh
double-edged battle in our most likely
deciding game of the sinfield goth
now in our kamsky nakamura game i and
despite what
mori said i still like nakamura's choice
of playing the sicilian if we fault
anything
it might be in retrospect the specific
variation
but um it's too early to say that i
think that i still feel like nakamura
has had some experience in these
positions and
uh might think it's a worthy positional
gambit and we did get a question from
one of our twitter followers um who said
uh
isn't it nakamura castle
uh yes we should probably specifically
um to be fair they didn't ask in this
position but here of course it would it
would just straight up drop a
drop a queen to castle right because
nakamura has played this move knight to
d7
to um open up his bishop and to what
else is 97 doing let's see
well i was going to say you know it's
very very dangerous don't do this at
home
uh children and amateur players do
castle bring your king into safety
especially in a semi-open position like
this i mean this isn't like
it's not as open as a double king pond
but that's why they call the sicilian
the classical like
semi-open position right right it's not
you don't have any completely open files
but you have some trades and
that creates enough dynamism that
usually keeping your king in the center
is quite dangerous
exactly very very risky and we've
mentioned that this move e4
e5 hangs over black's position like the
sword of damocles
you have to be cognizant that this move
e5
can blow open the position so this
retreat
if you will knight d7 was
by hikaru was showing his awareness that
he
was concerned very deeply concerned
about the movie e4
e5 so i see that as a defensive move to
stop this well
now uh god has said hey listen if you're
going to step backwards i'll step
up and again a reference to
olfa anderson and the whole
dragondorf is that dragondorff i hadn't
heard that
that mixture of the nydorf as well as
dragon
uh white stepped up he said look look at
that
look at my purty knight in the middle
a little suicidal okay yes i like it i
mean i'm a
i'm an old pawn grubber so let's look at
this it's pretty terrible so
it's nice that we could grab a pawn for
ourselves and have some exactly so
bishop
takes b2 now here at this moment
i'm kind of thinking that my rook need
not attack your bishop that you're just
going to
you're just going to start attacking
like queen f4 or something no
i'm just going to swing over here with
the idea that
look your bishop may end up getting
trapped offsides
and i'm i think i'm threatening c2c3
if your bishop went back just to show
one example
of the type of dynamic opportunities
that white has in the position
this bishop on h4 we've seen uh in
that game between gary caspar and judith
pogar
how night takes and bishop takes
one how about this line of play
something along the ideas of let me
throw this move in first
bishop on g3 coming down here
attacking this pawn on e7 and i'm really
looking at opportunity to play queen f4
so like for instance if e6 in this
position
e6 in this position you might just play
queen f4
here queen f4 actually even looking at
you you just want to play you stick your
knight into e7 i
am i really like really the possible the
tactical possibilities in this position
for white are very rich i mean even
after bishop b2 i'm looking for ways to
maybe sacrifice my work on anyone play
queen f4
there's going to be a load of tactics in
this game and it looks too favorable
i think this is really really too
dangerous it's dangerous but white does
have to pick one line
right that's the thing he's got so many
promising opportunities and
it'll be difficult to find it find the
the right way to twist the knife here
i don't know it looks really really uh
promising for white and this is
not i mean i know um
uh hikaru can be very provocative and
grab ponds like that but i think at this
level
against godakamsky in the last round no
my problem though is if i don't grab
that pawn i don't like my position that
much either you still have a lot of
those same tactical ideas
um grandmaster maurice ashley has some
thoughts on all this
jen the engines agree with you a hundred
percent
they don't like nakamura's position at
all
well we didn't need them to tell us that
the position looks terrible i mean
how did he get here well he got real
risky with the move g4
his pawn structure is weird it's hard
for him to castle white's pieces
white's not doing anything white's just
putting pieces on good squares
and they look fantastic and you can't
make any simple moves
to deal with that the capture on b2 is
actually the best suggestion but we know
engines are greedy to grab stuff but if
not the idea you mentioned yes c3 could
happen
the rooks will just swing to the center
and this black king is going to be
in a stare down about to be slapped off
the board
if bishop takes b2 very rambunctious
line there's some crazy lines
to look at rook ab1 i picked one of them
that was real entertaining
check this out bishop to e5 and now
bishop takes on e5
and the correct move is pawn takes
because if you were to play the move
knight takes on e5
this nasty move shows up knight to b6
attacking the rook in the corner
threatening to move bishop to a4
pinning the king to the queen and you
can't touch this knight because of
bam bishop takes check and after takes a
discovery
on your queen so that's a nasty line
which says after bishop takes on e5
you should take back with the pawn and
now things get even
more weird after knight to e3 bishop to
e6 and rook fd1
and things are just getting scary now
all of white's pieces mobilize black
king
still in the middle of the board the
computer gives b5 as the best move and
after bishop takes e6
your favorite move yes pawn takes on e6
to guard
from the incursion on these squares and
it says white just has a smidgen of
advantage here
should go for c4 and blast the game open
as quickly as possible
down a paw will be white but with some
play but not enough only 0.32 believe it
or not
for white here in this position saying
that black still has great
fighting chances man chess is a crazy
game
back to you jen and yes indeed nakamura
waving a red flag in front of godakamsky
and we're going to see uh
how that goes and what attacking uh path
of many to choose from
gotta select i have to say that was an
entertaining line thank you maurice for
sharing that because
uh the triplets on e7 e6 e5 you don't
see that every day
and you know we talk about weak double
pawns weak triple pawns victor korchnoy
would just be shaking his head
saying okay you know i'm going to have
to teach you guys
more lessons on strategical play but
that was wild
and only to think that it was slightly
better for
for white boy that really throws me
backwards
that's one of those positions that's
very difficult to play for black but
is nakamura up to the task we will find
out more we are going to take our first
break here at the sink field cup and
don't go away we're going to have a
winner here
in a few hours darn we have to go
welcome back to the sinfield cup we have
our final round action here today
and we haven't been disappointed so far
kamsky going for a super aggro
treatment against nakamura's night or
even though he has nothing to win or
lose in this game
so just going for it well absolutely i
feel great sympathy for
god kamsky our u.s champion in this
event
he's played really bold aggressive chess
and really he's been victimized more
than
anybody i can recall in a single
tournament for his uh
bold play he's he's been the one who's
been carrying a lot of the action
and he's doing it again today and not
only not punished but not sufficiently
rewarded
well that's the point he's not been
rewarded he's been so
much so victimized by counter attacks
and in this game
with this move knight d5 he's he's
challenged
uh hikaru to capture the pawn
uh hikaru as in distress
strategically so jen he did take the
pawn
might as well you're going to get
attacked you might as well have a little
pawn for something in the pocket right
yeah bishop takes b2 has been seen
and oops let me just refresh the board
because i wanted to get the times
i apologize to the audience while we're
waiting for you to do that
um one of the things you mentioned about
garakamski it doesn't seem like he's
playing that
terribly but you look at his score and
it's like wow he's getting crushed and i
think that goes to show
the strength of the tournament and we
actually have the world rankings here
um that underlies that number
number one play in the world with us for
the first time in america
magnus carlson not his first time in
america but his first time playing a
major event here
exactly and he's the last before the
world championship which is a huge honor
um levon aronian second in the world
first major tournament exactly and
nakamura our
own homegrown talent here in the united
states
number five in the world that makes
everybody um on the especially on the
internet very proud
um and 26 in the world agata kamsky
but sometimes he's number ten as we
mentioned yesterday he
kind of bounces around a lot and that 26
in the world
accounts for the fact that he hasn't had
an easy time here at the singh field cup
absolutely and the position is just
blown open in the game between
godakamsky and hikaru nakamura
hikaru is going to have to wear a
defensive hat
in this encounter for many moves to come
we've seen this move rook b1 bishop
dropped back to e5
maurice was showing the remarkable line
where you get tripled
pawns